I was very inspired by Steve Jobs when
he said that do something that makes a
dent in the universe right and years ago
when I was in the United States working
with the Bank of New York to melon
Global I used to constantly think about
what can I do which can make a
difference in the in the world and I
realized that if I do something for
India which has 140 crore or 1.4 billion
people a lot of them below you know the
lower standards of living that one would
expect I think I would have made a
significant contribution
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of fam Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
C-Tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we
are with Rishi agrawal the CEO and
co-founder of team lease regtech India's
leading regulatory SAS company his
company helps India Inc navigate the
complexity of the country's regulatory
ecosystem and stay on the right side of
the law he is envisioning compliance 2.0
a paperless presence-less and cashless
ecosystem for digital India he works
closely with Union and state governments
to help them reimagine employer
compliance he is an avid traveler and
amateur photographer and has recently
published a coffee table photo book
titled Varanasi a passage to immortality
Rishi agrawal welcome to 20-minute
leaders thank you so much for being with
me today how are you
doing very well Michael looking forward
to having a great chat with you today
same here same here thank you very very
much for being with me hey Rishi I we're
gonna talk about you know a bunch of
things both your own Journey but also
talking about compliance and talking
about India and team lease regtech and
so very excited to understand a little
bit about you know the way that you're
thinking through compliance and
regulation companies and in India and
and so obviously with uh you know with
with the global audience here this is
going to be really interesting to hear
about the perspective of specifically
where you're coming from and the
opportunity that you're observing as an
entrepreneur so again thank you very
much for being here tell me a little bit
about your life about sort of what what
what your journey was leading up to team
lists regtech yeah so Michael I
graduated I studied in India most of the
time I graduated from an engineering
College it's well known around the world
it's called IIT Indian Institute of
Technology back in 1999 in mechanical
engineering they took up a management
program at Indian Institute of
Management in Kolkata that ended in
2001. from there I got picked up lucky
enough to get picked up by one of the
multinational Banks the largest
financial services company in the World
Bank of New York Miller
spent about 12 years working with them
first six in the United States New York
New Jersey area and then returned to
provide leadership to their offshore
developments at uh which had become a
critical element of their value delivery
back in 2007 so from 2007 to 2013 I was
based in India between two cities
Chennai and Pune where I was providing
leadership to the Bank of New York
mellons offshore Development Center
where I was leading a sizable a few
thousand people in technology around all
of product delivery and so on and so
forth two thousand
three quit the bank entrepreneurial each
had become very strong I had to scratch
it
um and that was also a year when uh you
know uh the company law in India was
changing from companies Act of 1956 was
being replaced by companies Act of 2013
um you know Indian company law practices
were getting aligned with the global
practices uh you know
compliance was becoming an important
element corporate governance was
starting to become a key boardroom
agenda and I looked around and we
recognized that if India has to get to
its logical Destiny uh and continue to
grow between six and eight percent uh on
an annual basis a regulatory cholesterol
will become a key binding constraint in
its cold journey and that prompted an
entrepreneurial stint started a company
called aventis which eventually became
teamly Zach Tech and that was how I
became an entrepreneur
that's really really cool
um talking about compliance and
regulation how did that come about
it's really interesting you say that
because uh you know I I will have to
take a step back give a larger context
of India and why compliance is so
important in solving this problem is so
important in the context of India so you
know let me just uh take a step back
here uh I'm sure many of your audience
already know that India is a younger
Nation the population in the developed
world has been aging and all the four
factors of production which is land
labor capital and Entrepreneurship are
converging in India at this point in
time there are 800 million Indians which
are connected to high-speed uh you know
low cost internet earlier it was 4G and
now uh it is 5G as it is being rolled
out there was a time when India had
enough of land and labor labor was not
very skilled land was not very
productive and there was a dearth of
capital and hardly any entrepreneurship
most of the Indians were looking to find
jobs in the government sector today that
situation has changed where there are
about seventy thousand seven thousand
new startups which have come up in the
last few years we just saw our 100th
unicorn happen and it's very clear that
not just the land and labor capital and
Entrepreneurship have also started
happening in India companies which were
already incumbent or growing and new
companies are happening a lot of global
companies are making their base in India
and with what has happened during the
covet years and the global uh Supply
chains which are reconfiguring more and
more companies are setting up their shop
in India now with that said why is
compliance important because India has
been perceived as one of the most
regulated places in the world where ease
of doing business has not been there so
staying on the right side of the law has
always been a challenge and that's where
you see today only 11 percent of Indians
are a part of manufacturing which was
the case many years ago in the United
States and our manufacturing jobs have
really not grown and we realized that
one of the key reasons why this is the
case is a perceived you know ease of
doing business scenario the time it
takes to set up a new company the time
it takes to get licenses registrations
and permissions the number of
compliances unique compliance is leading
to returns registers and Challenge
number of ambiguous laws number of
different kinds of regulators and Thief
terms that are out there they create an
extremely complex environment to work in
and we realized that if India grows at
the rate it is eyeing to grow
more and more companies will deal with
this problem
so yeah in 2013 we thought how do we
create technology-based Solutions which
can actually help corporates stay on the
right side of the law so originally the
pursuit started with that thought and
along the way as we started working with
hundreds and thousands of companies and
entrepreneurs in India across many
different sectors so today I have
clients up to about 46 different
Industries in India last of the planes
are working on our platform so as we
worked with them we started identifying
what is not right with India's
regulatory ecosystem when we started
writing extensively publishing research
on that extensively and the government
wanted to solve this problem it just
didn't know what the exact problem was
that needed to be solved so when we
started publishing this we not only
started serving the corporates we also
started engaging with the governments at
Union state and local body levels and we
started this journey which is a positive
spiral to uh to reduce uh Regulatory
Compliance requirements via four Vector
framework of rationalize simplify
digitize and decriminalize so that's how
the overall Journey began and compliance
became a key Pursuit for us and the
company
phenomenal so what is the product how
does it actually work
so it's a big product uh SAS product uh
multi-tenant architecture available via
both web and mobile uh the product in
very simple terms you can conceptualize
it as a compliance Erp where it helps
you manage
the entire compliance its nuances its
complexity across the law of the land uh
for a business that you have a single
entity single location business or you
may be a multi-entity multi-location
manufacturing or Services organization
with corporate office head office you
know manufacturing centers warehouses
service centers sales offices across the
country so our product basically helps
you stay on the right side of the law
make sure that you can move from an ad
hoc People based and people dependent
compliance program to a highly
systematic digital uh you know process
based compliance program
okay and so walk me through perhaps sort
of a a typical engagement that you might
have with a company working with you how
would that work
sure so imagine a pharmaceutical company
working in India I mean there are over 3
000 Pharma companies we are actually the
pharmacy to the world during covert uh
this sector was uh under a lot of
Spotlight because we were supplying
drugs to the rest of the world with
disrupted Supply chains a lot of
companies in India Pharma companies in
India they work with us on on the on our
product to stay compliant now if you
look at a Pharma company they typically
have their corporate office in one of
the large Urban cities then they'll have
number of manufacturing plants they may
be doing few different kinds of things
they may be manufacturing apis uh or or
you know vaccines or they may be doing
drug Discovery they may be doing
clinical trials they may be
manufacturing generic drugs and so on
and so forth depending on what they are
doing which states in the country they
are located in uh what kind size of the
operation they are and what kind of
Human Resources they have how many
full-time employees employees contract
labor you know type of Labor skill
levels Zone in which they operate the
number of compliances the type of
compliances changes dramatically in
addition such a company will also deal
with a lot of equipments in their plants
hoists lives greens pressure vessels
boilers tools tackles gas holders fire
extinguishers all of these equipment
they have compliance requirements so
there are upfront requirements to get
licenses and registrations done and then
there are ongoing requirements for
periodic testing Fitness certifications
and so on and so forth each one of these
licenses may require some level of
renewal at some point in time now such a
company with four or five manufacturing
locations in the country will typically
deal with between three and five
thousand compliances on an annual basis
now cope is not a strategy if you want
to stay on the right side of the law
three to five thousand compliances
cannot be recorded in someone's memory
or the kind of depth advanced work that
is required in each one of them is not a
joke in addition there are 2233 websites
of various government in India which
publish regulatory updates it's not easy
to find the relevant regulatory updates
unless somebody section browsers through
many of these websites which might
publish a regulatory update so that
became an additional degree of
complexity for Indian businesses so our
product basically would help them
understand their current compliance
obligations the nuances around that
licenses registrations permissions
returns registers challans payments
remittances displays all of these are
flavors of compliances right and we
would map all of this identify the users
in their organizations with their
specific obligations and then they would
start working on the product and all the
regulatory updates that happen depending
on what their impact is and what the
assessment is would automatically flow
to the people there are smart dashboards
there is an integrated document
management system there is a integrated
takes there is a reminder alert
escalation notification engine there is
a Nuance approach to compliances because
there are time based event based and
checklisted compliances different
categories of compliances need different
way of dealing with them all of this
complexity has been subsumed uh you know
under the covers within the product and
once we bring the company on to the
product map all their users onto the
product and with an activation date they
go live and once they go live then the
product is a self-service product people
start using it they start managing the
life cycles of the daily monthly
quarterly half yearly annual and you
know multi-year compliances on them and
the entire record keeping is on the
product it bubbles up all the issues
non-compliances everything is risk
created
so it gives you risk-based reading
around house your company is outstanding
or residual risk with respect to
non-compliances it brings this to the
attention of the executive management to
help become create a culture of
compliance within the company that's how
the product works
wow
first of all fascinating and sounds
highly needed highly relevant and I
there were a few key things that I that
I uh that really um you know made an
impact first you know the notion of Hope
is not a strategy that was uh something
very unicorn and also you know the way
that you're talking about the growth of
India and how your how your sort of
balancing sort of this act and you're
thinking about it very holistically how
do you keep at The Cutting Edge of both
the company side and the compliance
regulation side you have to sort of play
both of these roles and you have to
maintain yourself at this intersection
The Cutting Edge how do you how do you
go about doing that
so we have two critical stakeholders
the first stakeholder is Corporate India
which helps us pay salaries at the end
of the month right second critical
stakeholders the government because
government has to continuously rethink
reimagine the future of compliance in a
fast growing economy of India right the
country is growing digital at a massive
peace we are already looking to become a
trillion dollar digital economy in the
next three four years right we already
do billions of transactions a month on
our digital platforms and so on and so
forth now in a situation like this while
the corporates want to stay compliant
today the government needs ideas for
tomorrow these ideas will take time to
get implemented time to get tested so
constantly we are working with both
stakeholders to ensure that one
stakeholder stays compliant today deals
with the complexity we catalyze a change
of culture and uh change of compliance
culture within their company so that
it's not one person's neck on the line
uh different people within the
organization position bring their
shoulder to the load compliance becomes
a shared responsibility of many
different people within the company so
that's that's an imperative which we
have for the corporate India and on the
government side uh we have to think 10
years 20 years into the Future come up
with ideas that will change the future
of compliance so we've been working with
them on you know Enterprise Digi Locker
how do we create only digital compliance
documents so paperless compliance
becomes a reality how do we make sure
there is an open API grid for us
published by various governments at
various levels who actually are
responsible for compliances so that
straight through filings can happen
automated reconciliations can happen
fraud detection you know default
detection delay detection can happen
Auto penalty calculations can happen all
of these are things that will require a
lot of deep thinking uh experimentation
assessments and then creating pocs which
will become reality in the next few
years so I think those are the two
critical stakeholders and we continue to
work with both of them are one piece the
salary and second will create a new
ecosystem of compliance in the country
if you had to if you had to extrapolate
the most interesting challenge that that
you may have to overcome over the next
couple years as you continue to grow and
as they're mentioning sort of this I
hear a constant evolution in the way
that you're speaking how would you
describe the most
um the most interesting challenge that
that you think you're going to be
positioned against
so I actually will give you two
challenges here Michael uh one is for
the corporate India as an entrepreneur
you know you have a limited ramp in that
ramp if you don't become profitable you
know uh you lose the opportunity to
somebody else so uh we have been
aggressively growing over the last few
years and my challenge for the corporate
India is to continue to grow
aggressively build our sales and
marketing organization uh bring more and
more customers across the industry both
private limited enlisted companies
Electra on our platform and push the
sales and marketing engine aggressively
so that we can continue to create cash
to reinvest into this business so that's
one challenge that I have on the
corporate side on the government side
the challenge is unless government
changes a lot of the ecosystem level
parameters digitizes the ecosystem
creates open apis creates single portal
for publishing all the regulatory
updates starts rethinking compliance so
that the next generation of compliance
can happen the ecosystem will reach a
status quo and that's where the Second
Challenge is really constantly pushing
the envelope identifying the hostility
that has been there in India's ecosystem
in the regulatory side uh working with
Regulators giving them ideas working
with the pocs so that some of these
ideas can see the light of the day
because that's how the future of this
industry will be determined
very very cool and wrapping up I I have
my favorite question which is why why do
you do what you do why are you so
excited and inspired about what you do
and why do you keep doing it every day
so I was very inspired by Steve Jobs
when he said that do something that
makes a dent in the universe right and
uh years ago when I was in the United
States working with the Bank of New York
to melon Global I used to constantly
think about what can I do which can make
a difference in the in the world and I
realized that if I do something for
India which has 140 crore or 1.4 billion
people a lot of them below you know the
lower standards of living that one would
expect I think I would have made a
significant contribution and Distilling
that thinking through it over the years
I recognized that if I can help create
more jobs in the economy if I can help
bring more investments into into the
economy I think I would do well in my
contribution to the world because so
many people live in India so that's how
we started working on the problem
identifying what can we do in order to
give back to jobs and employment and
investment and I recognize that if I do
my bit in resolving ease of doing
business as a problem or keep pushing
the agenda in that direction chances are
over a 10-year period uh some impact in
the economy would have been perceived so
that is a motivating factor for me to
keep doing what I'm doing I believe that
we are on to something good our business
is not just good for our shareholders
our business is good for the country as
well for the humanity as well because it
helps move in the right direction it
removes the bottlenecks through the free
flow of land labor capital and
Entrepreneurship in the country and it's
very exciting
that's uh really phenomenal and recently
I really want to thank you for coming
here and sharing with me your your your
experience your time and your energy it
was wonderful and I'm wishing you best
of luck will continue cheering from the
side and uh thank you very much for
being here I really appreciate it thank
you so much Michael I'm really excited I
look forward to speaking to you again
thank you